Now your solution may be a little bit different than ours, so let's take this
into account when walking through this code. Now you'll notice that the full
range of the indexes aren't actually used inside of grid. We allow, for
instance, a z index value to be between 0 and 100. But in reality we only use
about 10 or 11of them. But, the values we do use are actually scattered across
the number line. You have a bunch of them in the range of 20, some of them in
50, and then some of then in 90. The naive approach to this solution would be
to actually Create a simple for Loop, that would represent, and count through,
each of the Z index values, searching through the array, for any entity that
has that value, and rendering them. Rather than wasting the CPU cycles,
reiterating over the list, grips employs a bucketized method. What we do, is if
an entity is visible given our view rec, we'll actually go through and place
the entity, in a bucket, based on its Z index value. Much like the hash table
we used before with the entity class map. So, if we find that the zIndex for a
given entity already exists in our array, then we simply go ahead and add that
entity to our array. If we find that the zIndex for an entity does not already
exist in our array, then we go ahead, create a bucket for that zIndex, so that
future entities that have that same value can be sorted appropriately. Once
that's done, we go and ahead and assign this entity to its proper z index
bucket. Afterwards, we have a simple sorting function that will sort the
buckets by their z index value and then iterate over the buckets, drawing each
entity in turn.